- [Narrator] Russian flags,
photos of the Russian president
(upbeat music)
and children dancing to a
patriotic Russian pop song.
(nationalistic music)
These images from Ukrainian schools
and nurseries show the Kremlin's
efforts to give children
in the occupied territories
a Russian identity.
- The change at schools are one
of the most obvious, simplest
forms of Russification.
- [Narrator] The Wall Street
Journal examined videos
and photos shared by Russian authorities
to understand how Moscow is trying
to influence children
in the occupied regions.
(Vladimir speaking in Russian)
- [Narrator] Russia has been pushing
to incorporate four partially
occupied Ukrainian regions
into its legal, social
and economic systems
ever since it claimed
to annex them in 2022.
(people chanting in Russian)
Education has been key to these efforts.
Official posts show children
in the occupied regions learning
about the life of the composer
of Russia's national anthem,
celebrating Russian Science Day
and drawing the annexed Crimean peninsula
in the colors of the Russian flag.
- They're pushing a very
patriotic, pro-Russian curriculum.
- The Wall Street
Journal's Ian Lovett spoke
with families whose children
attended Russian-run schools
in areas retaken by Ukrainian forces,
as well as teachers who work there.
They told him that schools
under Russia's administration
largely left Ukraine and its
history out of the curriculum.
(nationalistic music)
- In the morning, at some schools,
the kids have to sing the national anthem.
There's now classes conducted
exclusively in Russian.
There is still, in some schools,
Ukrainian language class
but it's now taught as a foreign language.
- [Narrator] The Journal found
this document in a school
in the Kharkiv region,
outlining the goals of
secondary education.
One of them is to form
a Russian civic identity
among the students.
Moscow's efforts to
Russify Ukrainian children,
were also documented in a report
by the Yale School of Public Health.
It accused the Kremlin of
relocating Ukrainian children
to Russia and reeducating
them to become pro-Russian.
Following this report,
the State Department said
there was mounting evidence
of the Kremlin's aims to deny
and suppress Ukrainian
identity, history, and culture.
- The schools in occupied
territory also have the goal
of turning them into Russian children.
I think they're hoping
that in a generation,
they won't have as many
Ukrainians to fight against.
- [Narrator] Moscow denied having
forcefully relocated Ukrainian children,
despite multiple official images
showing Ukrainian orphans
arriving in Russia.
The Kremlin also denied
having special programs aimed
at the Russification of Ukrainian children
and said it creates
opportunities for all children
in Russia to study their native languages.
Ukrainian children are not only targets
of Russian propaganda, they
also became integral to it
as official photos and videos show.
- Schools themselves and
the kids who attend them
have been turned into parts
of Russian propaganda,
which I think is mostly
targeting Russian citizens
inside of Russia, with the goal
of showing them that
these Ukrainian regions
are eagerly accepting our
liberation is what they call it.
- [Narrator] Here, school
children form the shape of a star
and hold Russian flags to
commemorate the Defender
of the Fatherland Day,
a holiday which celebrates
Russia's armed forces.
And these are letters children wrote
to Russian soldiers on
the front line in Ukraine.
One letter shows a
Russian flag and a tank,
and wishes soldiers health,
strength, and victories.
Schools across Russia
have placed more emphasis
on patriotic education since
the invasion of Ukraine began.
But the consequences for children
in occupied Ukrainian regions
could be far reaching.
- Even if the occupation
doesn't last for forever
in some of these areas,
if they get six months
or a year or two years with these kids,
that's probably gonna have
a very profound impact
on the way those kids think
about Ukraine and Russia.
(pensive music)